نحن نشهد ارتفاعًا قياسيًا في حالات الوفيات
والاستشفاء في الولايات المتحدة في الوقت
الحالي وهذه
الأرقام تتصاعد إلى أي مدى تتوقع
أن تزداد الأمور سوءًا خلال الأشهر
الثلاثة أو الأربعة المقبلة قبل أن
يتوفر اللقاح على نطاق
واسع للأسف في الأشهر الأربعة إلى الستة
المقبلة.
يمكن أن يكون أسوأ الوباء أه
توقعات ihme تظهر أه
أكثر من 200000 حالة وفاة إضافية إذا
أردنا إه اتباع القواعد في
لبس الأقنعة
وعدم الاختلاط أه يمكننا تجنب
نسبة كبيرة من تلك الوفيات لذلك في
المدى القريب هي  إنها أخبار سيئة ،
لقد دقت ناقوس الخطر بشأن
التهديد الذي تشكله الأمراض المعدية
والأوبئة لسنوات
حتى في أحلامك الأشد جموحًا ، هل كنت
تعتقد أنه سيصبح هذا سيئًا في
الولايات المتحدة ،
لا أعتقد أن الولايات المتحدة ستقوم
بعمل أفضل  تعاملت مع الأمر
بشكل عام عندما قمت بالتنبؤ في عام
2015 ، تحدثت
عن الوفيات التي يحتمل أن يتم توظيفها ، لذا
قد يكون هذا الفيروس أكثر فتكًا
مما هو عليه لم نحصل على أسوأ حالة
ولكن الشيء هذا أه
فاجأني أن التأثير الاقتصادي
في الولايات المتحدة وحول العالم كان
أكبر بكثير من
أه التوقعات التي قدمتها قبل خمس سنوات
تعلمون أننا يجب أن ننظر جميعًا إلى
ما تعلمناه من هذا الوباء لأنه
سيكون هناك وباء آخر قادم
و  مهما كانت تلك الإدارة التي
تعرفها ، كونك ذكيًا في
إجراء الاختبار بسرعة
مما يسمح لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض الذين هم الخبراء أه
لإعطاء رسالة للجمهور
لا تخاف من الأخبار السيئة أه
حتى نجهز الناس
أه تعلم أن الأمر واضح جدًا أه
سنكون أكثر ذكاءً في المرة القادمة
آمل ذلك ولكن دعنا نتحدث عن
هذا الوباء في المستقبل
أم ماذا تعتقد أن إدارة بايدن
يجب أن تفعله للاستعداد له من
الواضح أننا لم نكن مستعدين أه لهذا الوباء
على الأقل لا  بالدرجة التي نحتاجها لأن
نكون بحاجة إلى فريق
من الخبراء مثل 3000 من جميع أنحاء العالم
يعملون على الأمراض المعدية عندما يكون
هناك تلميح لوباء ،
فإنهم سيتحركون بمهاراتهم
الكاملة ويتحركون  بسبب ذلك ،
يتوفر فريق أفضل من الأشخاص
لمراقبة أفضل للوصفة الطبية للحصول
على هذا الأمر بشكل صحيح
، طالما أننا نتذكر مدى سوء هذا
الأمر ونحن على استعداد
لدفع أي مبلغ سيكون فقط تعرف
المليارات في السنة
أه لتتجنب أه تعلم  تريليونات من
كارثة الدولارات أعتقد أن خارطة الطريق
واضحة وقد
تحدثت مع الرئيس المنتخب
عن ذلك
وأه تعلم أعتقد أن مؤسستنا
ستكون جزءًا من هذا الحوار للتأكد من
أننا لن
نفجره مرة أخرى